whether you like it or not Sam Beekman
freed probably didn't do anything wrong
he's probably innocent why do you think
he hasn't been arrested yet why do you
think he's just out and about enjoying
life right now at his 40 million dollar
mansion in the Bahamas the Bahamas does
have an extradition treaty with the US
so if he's so obviously guilty why
hasn't he been extra Dead Yet the media
YouTubers everyone is complaining about
how he misused customers funds that Sam
bakeman freed broke the law that he's
just a stupid weirdo that doesn't know
what he's doing but the reality is Stan
Beckman freed is no dum-dum listen I
know you're probably praying for his
downfall but everything he did he
probably did legally that's because he
knows how to take advantage of the
system and you don't but fear not
because in this video we're gonna break
down exactly why prepare to be triggered
you want to know what no one talks about
how both of Sam's parents are law
professors but not just any law
professors they're some of the best law
professors in America they teach us
Stanford the second best law school in
America and what kind of law do they
specialize in while the mother worked at
a top 10 U.S law firm called Paul Weiss
a law firm that specializes in defending
fossil fuel companies like Exxon while
the father he's one of the leading
experts in tax law tax shelters and tax
compliance according to his page on
Stanford in other words Sam Beckman
freed had the perfect lorus behind his
back he had some of America's best
lawyers in the realm of legal compliance
for businesses lawyers that specialize
in making sure everything a business
does stays within the bounds of the law
and when you start to look at how FTX
was legally structured you start to see
his parents influence everything was
done perfectly they had a web of
subsidiaries and licenses in the Bahamas
Australia Cyprus Switzerland United Arab
Emirates Japan Singapore something like
this would have required someone with
years of legal experience and a really
big big team of lures to set up so I
would be truly shocked if Sam did all
this on his own it had to have been his
parents he's traveling with Mark Widgeon
a former chairman of the cftc now what
was Mark doing for him I have no idea
was it credibility or just carrying his
briefcase or I should say his backpack
and then he's got Ryan Miller Ryan
Miller is the former uh council at the
cftc and became general counsel of the
cftc and this guy's sitting at a bar
could barely pick his head up saying to
me why won't you let us grow I said he
said he's worth 26 billion I'm assuming
you've been growing pretty good here
which is also why Sam went out of his
way to cleanly separate the U.S branch
FTX U.S from FTS International why
because legality what's legal is based
on your jurisdiction where you're
legally located FTX by all accounts was
legally located in the Bahamas sand Bape
and freed is based in the Bahamas his
team was in the Bahamas with them and
his business is registered in Antigua
and Barbuda this allowed Sam to do
something very
see U.S financial loss are extremely
strict one wrong move and you'll end up
in prison knowing this Sam purposely put
an FTX Us's terms of service that they
were not gonna touch U.S customers funds
and he probably didn't dare mess with
that money but internationally anything
goes it's the Wild Wild West think about
it there's no International laws there's
no International police or Court you can
take a white-collar criminal to if you
had an international crypto company and
your International crypto company
misuses customers funds in let's say
Japan and then Japan issues a warrant
for your arrest so what just don't
travel to Japan or a country that has an
extradition treaty with Japan it's not
simple so Sam probably did do super
sketchy illegal stuff internationally
but would he break the law in the U.S
would he misuse U.S customers funds
given his law professor parents given
that he's put an insane amount of effort
and money into their legal structure to
separate their U.S entity from their
International ones given that Sam has
invested literally tens of millions of
dollars to enact U.S crypto regulations
and give been a myriad of other things
we're about to go over do you really
think Sam would be dumb enough to break
U.S laws do you think he would be dumb
enough to mess with U.S customers funds
I would bet that he's probably innocent
in the only jurisdiction that matters
but like many modern crucifixions before
him the U.S justice system will probably
still screw him stay dangerous subscribe
for more and here's why
[Music]
the world is falling into a recession
right now which means things are about
to get a lot worse however if you're
looking to start a business right now
this is actually a good thing Apple
Airbnb Microsoft Netflix Uber and a ton
more were all started during a recession
and one of the best businesses to start
right now is e-commerce you know Dr
squash with those funny bar soap ads
they make over a hundred million dollars
per year dude wipes who literally just
sells wipes is valued at 300 million
dollars while athletic greens they're
valued at over a billion dollars so if
you're going to start an e-commerce
brand or you have one already you're
gonna need super fast efficient and
affordable shipping especially around
the holiday season coming up that's why
you gotta check out shipstation today's
video sponsorship station is the easiest
most efficient and most affordable
shipping software out there that's
already helped over 130 000 e-commerce
Brands grow their company ship station
is so good that 98 of companies that use
shipstation for a year keep using it for
as long as they're in business with
shipstation you'll have access to the
best shipping carriers and highly
discounted rates that are normally only
available to Giant companies it works
for more than 300 different platforms
including Amazon Etsy and more you can
ship anywhere in the world you can
automate every shipping test with just a
few clicks and you can even handle
orders right from your phone plus
shipstation is also available in the UK
Australia and Canada this holiday season
give yourself the gift a stress-free
holiday shipping by going to
shipstation.com jaketran for a 60-day
free trial that's two months of Cheaper
easier shipping completely free so go to
shiftstation.com with the link below
right now thanks to shipstation for
sponsoring this video
foreign
[Music]
to truly understand this FTX debacle we
need to rewind back to 2014 when Sam
bankman freed or SBF graduated from MIT
and had big plants he wanted to be a
hedge fund manager that specialized in
crypto he never wanted to create an
exchange there was only one problem to
open a successful hedge fund you need to
be able to raise money from investors
and to do that you either need to be
really well connected to New York's Wall
Street Elite or you need a proven track
record working with hedge funds SBF had
neither of those things he's from
Silicon Valley he was an outsider to the
world of hedge funds so he took a
different route he still created his own
hedge fund in 2017 and he still needed
to raise money but instead of trying to
raise money through his hedge fund he
ended up creating a tech startup to
raise money through instead Tech startup
called FTX after all as a Silicon Valley
Insider raising money for a tech startup
was much more doable compared to raising
money for a hedge fund so in 2018
SBF officially moved his hedge fund
named Alameda research to Hong Kong so
it wouldn't fall under American Finance
laws and a year later he registered the
FTX crypto Exchange in Antigua and
Barbuda after another year of scraping
by FTX International started gaining
momentum and then boom Sam all of a
sudden started having Venture
capitalists in Silicon Valley investors
try to throw money at him all of a
sudden raising money for his hedge fund
was no longer an issue the only problem
was they weren't trying to throw money
at him for his hedge fund but for FTX
with the funding problem solved all he
needed to do was move the Investor's
money from FTX to his hedge fund Alameda
research and he had to do it legally so
what he did was he loaned some of the
investors money from FTX to Alameda
research in the form of a loan alone
that elevator research would
theoretically have to pay back and as
long as investors are aware that you're
moving this money into a company you
control like this it's perfectly legal
think about it if you were in Sam's
shoes your investors trust you they
think you're this genius all you would
have to say is hey guys I think the best
way for us to make more money is to move
some of our customers funds into my
sophisticated hedge fund that made 20
million dollars in early 2018. it's a
perfectly legal business move and what
most people forget is that your
Traditional Bank is doing this right now
with your money your money isn't there
they're putting it into other
Investments loaning it out and pocketing
the difference
so Sam had this mutually beneficial
relationship between both companies
which is actually more common than you
think he raised money for his tech
company and then transferred that money
to his private company while being
really good with disclosing everything
to investors suddenly both Alameda
research and FTX were growing at insane
rates but that wasn't enough for SBF he
wanted to expand even more and get into
the American crypto market so SBF
created FTX us a completely separate
crypto exchange that would follow all
the US government's super strict rules
he also created more than 130 FTX
subsidiaries around the world to limit
his liability if he ended up doing
something illegal with one of them so
basically FTX us would do everything by
the book it would follow the rules to
the letter
outside of the us though it was all fair
game
a perfect example of this is Uber in
2013 it was expanding internationally
and one of those expansions was to South
Korea even though its ride sharing was
technically illegal there launching Uber
in South Korea meant that Uber's CEO
would be breaking the law over there but
did Uber give up no they just expanded
into South Korea anyways and the South
Korean government just had to suck it up
and pray that one day the CEO willingly
travels over there to get arrested last
we checked the CEO of uber is still not
sitting in a South Korean jail cell and
that's exactly what Sam and his parents
did with FTX and once he had that clean
split between FTX us and FTX
International he pretty much had free
reign to do whatever he wanted with FTX
International including pouring billions
of dollars into his now British Virgin
Islands based hedge fund Alameda
research
[Music]
with FTX funding elevator research it
was time for the hedge fund to do what
hedge funds do best gamble that's
because there are only two ways hedge
funds make money they typically make two
percent off of all money they manage no
matter how they perform and they make a
giant 20 off of all gains they make
while not getting penalized for any of
the losses so what would you do if you
were in charge of a hedge fund and the
only way to make more money was to get
insanely High gains but you don't get
punished for your losses you would take
the money investors gave you and use
that money to borrow even more money
we're talking anywhere from five times
to the amount of money you have to ten
times or more so if you had a billion
dollars from investors you could borrow
5 billion 10 billion maybe even more
this is also known as leverage or
Levering up and then you would take all
all that money in debt and place it on
the riskiest bets you can possibly find
after all why not you're not gonna
suffer the losses so why not shoot for
the sky and if you come crashing down
yeah well and that's probably what
Alabama research did too in total it
borrowed around 10 billion dollars from
FTX including half of the 16 billion FTX
had in customer funds but that's when
SBF took it to an even higher level that
would make hedge funds drool at the
mouth see the more money elevator
research had the more it could borrow
from lenders right which got SBF
thinking what if he could create a
crypto token and use that to boost
alameda's assets and then use that
inflated number to take on more leverage
to trade with genius here's how it
worked FTX created a crypto token called
ftt ftt was a legit token in the sense
that ftt holders get discounts on
transactions when they traded on FTX and
the price of ftt fluctuated based on
people buying and selling it just like
any other coin but behind closed doors
SPF used elevator research to buy a
bunch of ftt tokens artificially pumping
the price of ftt and then Alameda would
sell those tokens at a profit and buy
some more so the price for ftt would
keep going up again all of this was done
internationally and not in the US as far
as We Know
now that elevator research had pumped
the price of ftt it used inflated ftt
tokens it had on hand as collateral to
take on even more loans from Banks so it
had even more money to trade with
if anyone was naive enough to believe
ftt tokens were actually as good as cash
then that was their own problem so FTX
and Alameda took out these massive loans
and built up billions in assets
all based on a crypto token that only
had value because Alameda propped it up
in the first place and because all FTX
and alameda's money was tied up in these
loans as collateral whenever people
wanted to withdraw their money from the
exchange it would basically use other
clients deposits to pay them back and
everything would be perfectly okay as
long as a bunch of people didn't want to
withdraw their money at the same time
that would never happen right but then
the May 2022 crypto crash happened and
more than one trillion dollars in
cryptocurrency value was wiped out and
SBF thought this crash was the perfect
time to bail out and take control of
some of his competitors
foreign
research used billions of dollars to
bail out crypto companies including
Voyager and blockfi if they could turn
these companies around and make them
profitable Alameda would be looking at
billions in profit but unfortunately
that didn't happen instead Voyager
declared bankruptcy taking at least half
a billion dollars with it and since
crypto didn't make a magical comeback
the other company's Alameda invested in
weren't far behind suddenly Alameda
research was billions of dollars in the
red and on the verge of collapse and
that's when SPF did the unexpected he
took a 4 billion dollar loan from FTX to
Alameda research without properly
informing investors at some point SPF
must have realized that there is a
legitimate chance that everything could
come crashing down so instead of waiting
for FTX and Alameda to potentially go
under SBF got proactive and took one
billion dollars out of FTX for himself
in the form of a personal loan that way
if Alameda and FTX went down he still
would have made one billion dollars for
his efforts after all there's nothing
wrong with taking a loan from a company
if you promise to pay it back with
interest and if that company goes
bankrupt before you can pay it back it
depends on how it goes in bankruptcy
court but in his case he'll probably be
good his top Executives weren't far
behind either with ftx's head of
engineering taking a 543 million dollar
loan and the head of digital markets 55
million dollars and yet again all of
this would get you in trouble if you did
it in the US with U.S customers money
but it was all probably done with the
FTX International money however Sam
bankman freed did screw himself over
just not in the way you expect
[Music]
in 2015 Martin shkreli became the most
hated man in America when he acquired
the manufacturing license of a drug and
raised the price of it by
5455 percent from 1350 to 750 dollars
per pill greedy yes illegal definitely
not but regardless the public hated him
and demanded Justice the problem was he
didn't do anything illegal in this case
so what did prosecutors do they dug into
his past and charged him for things
completely unrelated to what everyone
was mad about
he was sentenced to seven years in
federal prison and up to 7.4 million
dollars in fines he was just released
early in May 2022 the same thing
happened to Elizabeth Holmes of theranos
she was accused of lying to investors
about how accurate her company's blood
testing devices were but they couldn't
find any legal grounds to charge her
specifically for that so once again they
just found a way to charge her for
something unrelated to what the masses
were mad about She was recently
sentenced to jail for committing wire
fraud because that's just the way it
works in America see attorney generals
and prosecutors are elected officials
their one and only job is to find high
profile people the public hates and find
a way to crucify them and send them to
jail that's their only job to protect
the public interest as they would call
it and when they can't pin and actual
crime to what everyone is mad about
simple the average American commits
three felonies a day there are so many
laws and regulations that you don't even
know you're committing a crime why
because it's by Design as a great writer
once wrote quote there's no way to rule
innocent men the only Power any
government has is the power to crack
down on criminals well when there aren't
enough criminals one makes them one
declares so many things to be a crime
that it becomes impossible for men to
live without breaking laws who wants a
nation of law-abiding citizens what's
there in that for anyone but just past
the kind of laws that can neither be
observed nor enforced nor objectively
interpreted and you create a nation of
law Breakers and then you cash in on
guilt
so they'll simply just keep digging into
your past until they land on what they
need to put you behind bars and that
ladies and gentlemen is where Sam
bankman freed went wrong he tried to do
all the Shady stuff hedge fund and
bankers do while being in the public eye
he was trying to come off as this
altruistic eccentric billionaire like
Elon Musk and that model works for Elon
Musk with Tesla and SpaceX but when
you're dealing with people's deposits
the moment there's a scratch in your
reputation which can happen at any time
for any reason you are screwed and now
the vultures are circling
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]